today I'm gonna go beyond the travel ban
I'm going to go beyond deportations and
beyond the child separations that we've
been seeing I'm now going to go to a
proposal that was leaked this morning
which would be the biggest change to
American immigration law in decades and
decades Donald Trump wants to make it
more difficult for legal immigrants to
the United States people here legally to
become citizens or to get green cards
for permanent residency if they have
ever used a variety of public welfare
programs including Obamacare this is
it's one of those situations where my
vocabulary is exceeded by the emotions
I'm trying to convey it's stunning to
use a term that is probably an
understatement
if you think Congress wouldn't allow
this they would stop it number one I'm
not sure that they would but more
importantly number two doesn't appear
that Congress would need to because
legal experts are saying that Donald
Trump could do this could make these
changes without congressional approval
and based on the draft of the proposal
that NBC News learned about if you've
ever used Obamacare or chip children's
health insurance food stamps or a number
of other benefits you could be prevented
from getting permanent residency or
citizenship in the United States
20 million immigrants could be affected
in particular immigrants who work jobs
that don't pay well and would be likely
to utilize some of these welfare
programs and this appears to be coming
from not surprisingly it's not
necessarily Trump's idea but it is the
idea it seems of a harebrained extremist
advisor Stephen Miller who quite simply
just wants fewer immigrants getting
legal status in the United States unless
of course they're from Norway I wonder
what color most Norwegian immigrants to
the United States are informally this is
already taking place
NBC News spoke to immigration lawyers in
four different states here in
Massachusetts Tennessee Virginia as well
as in California they all said that
they're noticing more and more of their
clients being rejected when they apply
for green cards and for citizenship and
this is an attempt to scale up the
policy and make it more official I still
can't get past the fat
that trumps own wife is an immigrant
milania's parents are now here why are
they here are they the best which Trump
claims to want I don't know maybe they
are maybe they're not but beyond the
personal hypocrisy doesn't Trump
understand how many of the best people
we have in our country contributing in
ways that are considered American that
are economically stimulative they're
here only because either they or
sometimes their parents or grandparents
came here and we're able to stay as a
result of the exact laws and
infrastructure around immigration that
Donald Trump is looking to change if the
workers are paying taxes in the United
States how are you going to punish them
for using the services that their tax
money pays for if you used roads as an
immigrant's then you're not going to be
able to become a citizen well hold on I
worked and my taxes pay for those I'm
not allowed to use sorry just not gonna
happen
it's that would be the next step it's
it's an exaggeration but that's
effectively what we're talking about
programs you pay into you're punished
for paying for receiving benefits from
right like perhaps the argument would
hold up when you're talking about
undocumented immigrants because they
don't pay too much in taxes I mean there
are sales taxes and things here and
there but that's not we're talking about
we're talking about legal immigrants who
are paying those payroll taxes paying
those income taxes absolute just like a
US citizen would they came here legally
they followed the process which is
convoluted and long and complex they're
working the services exist it's legal to
obtain the services and you're gonna
punish them for it and say you're not
getting a green card or you can't get
citizenship this is retrograde dark ages
stuff were in Reverse and Trump smashing
the accelerator and we need him out ASAP
and you know at this point vote yes vote
in November right we got to take over
the house we've got to take over the
Senate but this is a change which
doesn't require congressional approval
so November very quickly is becoming
just a pit stop on the way to 2020